доброго дня я мар'яна простенько вчитель
качка в їхній владі але печерську школи
ми з колегами , економічних
консультантів
про проти нього за участю підсумку кита
підходи до нальчани я і право джиму їх у
роботу нашої початку ви і школи хочу вам
раз povestea протез як ми на чаєм і
дуже українську мову за допомогою
методично і системи д або five сюди не
5d або файл c such as напої до
нальчани я читаю і лист який ви курей
заснувати школа таких crane почету я
канада америка британія австралія ділі
5 щити не 5 систематично сивина
робота я діяльності я кіфф сидить і
класу в ікону witch дня у продаж 20
хвали
ключова ідея даної системи
вибору для дуже ще дня бітовий кону
це че то не і для себе
читаючи для вас слух вони працювали словами
та й лист для себе на ємність щедрина
Діяльність лист для себе я б не
назвала з ідеальністю вільний лист
ми там за без печі ти сиди на
виправлення у листі пасивному виклади
владних думок ще допомагаючи розвивати
і psn і зв'язкові молоді не дуже і
keepass тупого на буває stick їх
новачок і стою з колишніми письменниками
превью ніж лист для себе і занурення
пускових про українську мову хочеться за
значить 8 і право з українською
заповіт протирання конкретних навідників
засмоктуванні пивних форм у правління
грамоти з орфографії та пунктуації
is above я скований до вимог правил
інструкцій ви міг лист для себе
лист відвели їй у будь-якій формі безус
та реджині на правилах та структурі
основна задача
і ще дані діяльності хіба води
бажання 8 ви клада ти влада не думка і
ти діяльності 1 кого важливими не
я займу заміни протезу я буду пам'ятаю і
чим і
цик гри з правилами гри без правил
він бійтеся з правовим та розвивайте
вміння організувати і собі відриваю цієї
структури або порушення правил друге
ще без правил рясна ідеальність
століття розвиває творчість ну я чекаю
проду кого не нових ідей і до
самовираження я якраз почати роботу
над листом для саду
про свій клас вібрато дітей навколо
саме сказати і їм сьогодні ми раз пачино
йому роботу над листом для саду це така
діяльності друкаря і ви будете
записувати і влада не думки на за
пробку ново ну че
а лаю вам ітема так я до вас хочеться у
бутіки та формі
троянд по відео лох з досконалим твер буди
ким приладна і вся виручка матчі
фломастером і цін ваші думки їх парі
пірнати і від синього ти них тонни буде
це наш перший день
вид тощо. ми будемо у роботи тому для
себи шкіряного дня а бліда і тесс і пара
говоріть своїм другом чому на ваш обов'язок
у важливі в пасати для себе кожного дня
якщо облава раніше вчитель до монстра я
свої владним прикладом лист для саду
і озвучив владу не думкою волосся вигляд би
розкладуть бджоли стоп по п р о л о
ґрунтова св вибір на стрибав я брюс
тетрадь там ще хочеш і б моя думка і
чулося для мене я хочу їх збирання їх ти
і прочитати з нижчих абон я був витік
там ще сьогодні пишуть для свого друга
чим а ми ч учителя прибираючи
а ліфті чарочку сивий так щоб було
терміново проти ти потім враховували кажи
дітям ще сьогодні вин sc продуманий струмінь
на дощ і вже на дощ і записує
дату записують тему та в голос обидва run
the ви чому зразкам етюд і вся тема для
мене я вожу його оживити сьогодні я
тому сьогодні для чого вами ниць і
в процесі листа бен робот зуб інки
задуму вчися над словом і які складні в
написання її казенний вдавлений
ще знаючи їх посад і топить крісло та чому
важливі його запаси від і своєю думкою
говорити вчитель і записуючи на дощ та
я думаю ще лист ще дня до допоможемо і
не навчитеся ви слова т своєю думкою 8 я
навчуся правильно та красиво писати воно
буде cut em am я зможеш bracht з
вигадкою і прочитати їхні пісні she
я зможе робити зі свого думки ми з
друзями на стем і столітті живуть
далеко менше вкрай
практикуючі лист шкіряного дня розуму та
будням можливий статус про ж ним листі
нку
на прохолодних джоан ролинг та вигоду
історію навпаки етика вішу за гаррі
поттера закінчили у читай перевіряючи
і виправляємо кілька слив і кипить хрест
ліфчик яких травня sol не перевіряється тупо
мови немов до вчителя акценту та уваги
дуже на тому ще тексту мікро him to die
cool його пора читати і кілька разів і
внести правки раз на вигляд ще можна
повернути і прочитати вона ступ ново дня
будда добрі і всі, хто записує вчитель
на думку про пропустити а по дрібниці і на
пишний розбирав
щоб потім історії че правого дити
поважала ще листом, а я буду розбив
його їм відразу милим і без полиць потім
вчитель просто дуже його за про панова
ти провела я кезана дивується друку і
ідеальності такій особі маскова атака та
година я до і
і та й записувати на дощ і а з роком
оформляють на ватмані повік правила та яких
важливі і вода 3 мова ти спи час че-то не
я для себе
тип правило може стати і пунктами та
планку для самооцінювання своєї ви
тревал асті та засміченості яки форму йому
друкую цього листа для себе
кожного дня продажів персик я ти дні перед
початком роботи діти повторюють провалу
разом зачитуємо віку розрубала на
першому заняття для такої роботи на
чіткому етапі
не п'ять хвилин надходило годину дихається до
15 обидва 20 вчитель знаходиться пір і до
допомагає їм хто тіло вимагатиме і did i
віці кожухін і знає про рахунок висоти
знаємо і по три дно, оскільки ват через
пропана води кілька ідей на вибір на
гадот ще за їхню владу не думкою їх вас
не висловлювання і їм найму чого боялися ще
за siwon і виходить щось запропав його ти
намалювати своєю думкою таким дітям
потрібна година взводом он і починає
висоти але ж одне-два слова з тулилися
арменія побачиш потрібні всі стануть листі
ніками
теми які гидкі дити друку листи
для саду
моїх ніби для них важливі ви ми тиковим і
про них реальна по всьому будинку жити так
особини
рефлексія влада не дункана з пари теми
у роті розмістіть у класі на в одному
місці зараз там доповнити зраді та чим
важливішим буде і
кожному разу малий випер рентон немає м і
ще сьогодні обидва вчора в мене була цика
бувало ще б ламінарного ще дурного
нова прощаючи ми її все-таки добро і
подібно праворуч я зуби і який урок ми не
сподобився і чим біля річки юрок би ним не
сподобився і чому все-таки дружба після
талреп минуло п'ять хвилин іди ти
завершив і перша свою таку роботу ми
запитуємо, а він їх чистку домоглася їм
писати для себе
вам поточного на вигляд і дарувати ми не
подавайте черепахи, а тому що як
можна вишивати
вигадку на посадка шукає авічування
преподобної типу зітру для c тому
себе за різних смаків це моя ще й якун
добрий праворуч зуби і розумі я ще
обіймаю
добру стала лізогуб топом кохання бога
мабуть ви думаєте
калію будуть сару б ти на річ ми не
я набитий бачу висоти для себе можна на
бутикам вашому уроки від дістанемо 510
halen сьогодні можна заробити групі
продовженого дня на речах 4 лист для
себе це дуже шкіди його
і нераціонально ваш лист дуже у
нашій школі
ці навчаються інших класах фільму
пашить текст наблизив на одну starring
ще дня третіх і четвертих собі США
тому перелив тиф потрібного в два по
три рази пак і ніжно помічай ще
витерпів явити собі
дити вільну виставляють свої думки на
будемо cut em u